負けるものかよりも活動の方が強いんや
スタートでドンとピストルが鳴った瞬間に
ね240L捨てるんよこれが怖いんやね
レースの厳しさは1秒負けたら負けないよ
ねサンフランシスコからっとで世界記録
出されたと思うんですけどやってる時何を
考えてってたんですかモチベーションを
維持し続けるっていうのが難しいんだ勝つ
勝つでずっと来るわけやからね負けるもの
かよりも活動の方が強いんや当時から絶対
俺が優勝や言うて自分でも言っとったし
よその人も言っとった思んでねま負ける
わけないやないか思ってずっと
とやっぱりこう命に関わるもんで食料でも
水でもね最低限というのをつまんといかん
よそのチェックがあるんやけどな水はね1
日4l60日分2000Lだ240Lと
いうのは240kgということや
ものすごい重いわけよそいつがねそれまで
にね太平を渡ったのは3回やったんよ3回
までのずっと水の平均を見てみるとね1日
1勝だそれだけは十分ということよという
ことはゴールまで40日とみたいで40日
だから72Lあればいいハーフガロンって
いうのが大体2L弱やからね1ガロンの
ミネラルウォーターでプラスチックスの
あれに入っとるんやけどなそいつを20本
買ってくるんやでそいつを先体に並べとく
んやでその両方を割しといてねスタートし
た時に素だけの水は積んどらんといかんの
だけど使い方は自由ねスタートでドンと
ピストルが鳴った瞬間にね240L捨てる
んよこれが怖いんや
ね命の水やからなあっというに240km
軽なる風が後ろから吹いてくるおっての
レースやからね船は軽いほど早いこう
いろんなものをねこんなものを重くて乗せ
んわけよこれ乗せるんやったら
プラスチックすのねこんな小さなもう1個
ありゃええからな歯でも半分ありゃ磨ける
やろ半分切って1g1gと減らしていく
240km軽くなるっていうのは大喜び
よ完全のヨットの中に1人ってことですよ
ねそうだよ寝る時とかってどうすんですか
寝る時はね風に対して定の方向に走るよう
な装置があるわけそいつに任してね寝るん
よ寝るのは15分な寝たり起きたりしてよ
をそうそうそう風の方向なんて
しょっちゅうんやけどさコースが変わる
じゃないセールがねもうそんないい加減に
引っ張るんじゃないんよもキリキリんとこ
で風がこのカーブのとこから綺麗に1度と
狂わずに入ってくるように調整するわけ
そいつが風が変わったら強さも変わったり
スピードが変わったりしたら1度2度こう
ずれちゃうそいつもまた調整し直すんでね
ませ細かいんよヨッというのはね昼は
ヨットでパてるね昼はもうそのまま寝る
理由はないわな人間が火事を取った方が
早いんだから寝不足にならないですレース
の厳しさは1秒負けたら負けないよねそう
いうことやないだから40日もかかって1
秒負けた言ったら誰が褒めてくれるバカと
言われるに決まっとるやないなんでそこ
もうちょっと頑張らでだからもう頑張り
同士に頑張らないしょうないレースである
限り
ね何回目の参加で優勝した時の1人乗りと
しては2回目あとはみんな大勢でやるんや
からね沖縄が変換になったやろあの年にね
沖縄から三崎そこのミールハントなそこ
までのレースがあって第1回の沖縄レース
そこで我々が優勝したんよでそのあれから
もう何十年経つか知らんけどねその記録が
破られたのがつい最近ないそれまで我々が
ずっとその記録持っとっ
たヨトはねみんな大学に入ってからやるん
よ高校からやるやつもおるんやけどな野球
部に入ったらま小学校からやってるやつが
おるからかわんじゃんだけどよやみんな0
から始めるからね勝つ可能性のあるもんや
ないと大学までは何かスポーツ特にやって
ないなうん高校時代柔ちょっとやった
ぐらいのもんかなあれのね大学の時に運動
クラブばっかり集めてなそれを体育の時間
っていうのがあるんやでそこでどの運動部
が一番強いか言うてみんなはい腕立て伏せ
何回言ってやらせるわけよで飛ぶというの
はみんなものすごい強いで腕立て伏せ初め
言ってやってどんどんどんどんやって何百
回というのを超えてみんなも大体何十回の
隊員で脱落やろ俺が何百回でもやっとるん
やそのうち先生がままえ
どれだけできるんよさあ000回はやった
ことあるけどな歩くのと一緒でねれ
ないどの辺の力使うんですかね金腹筋それ
から肩やな今はまだあのいろんな道具を
使ってウンチなんて使って引っ張るもんで
軽いんやけどな昔はダイレクトに引っ張っ
とったやまなすが重いんやところがねこれ
みんな1年2年の頃にその力のいるところ
やらされるんやけどな中にはねこんな
10mm以上の12mmぐらいのロプをね
ぶっちぎるやつがおったよすごかった
な特に昔のあの朝ロープとか麺のロープと
違ってねネトロンかナイロンなんよ夫ない
にそいつがぶっちぎれもんねびっくりした
などういうトレーニングされたんすかただ
乗るだけ必要なとこしかいらんからな昔は
ほらウェットスーツなし手袋もなしあの靴
もなしでな冬に乗っとった死ぬようなもん
やな